we have to deal with the fact that the
nfl is handling or at least trying to
its first covet 19 outbreak of the
regular season on sunday there was a
near miss because aj tyrell the falcons
cornerback was placed on the covet 19
reserve list and there was an emergency
round of contact tracing and testing to
determine that no other falcons players
were positive and they'd be able to play
the bears falcons game that worked out
we now don't know what's going to happen
for the tennessee titans or the
minnesota vikings we should know more
today
as the 24-hour turnaround testing gives
us more of an insight as to how
widespread the outbreak is with the
titans who have three players and five
personnel who are
positive for covet 19 yesterday the news
came out of nowhere after we went off
the air yeah titans vikings shutting
down
their facilities titans closed until
saturday titans may have to play the
steelers on sunday without the benefit
of a single practice we don't know at
this point what's going to happen so
the bottom line is
it finally occurred just
and i i don't know we may have jinxed it
yesterday chris because i said hey the
good news is we've gotten through three
weeks 48 games no issues this is fine
they've got it under control until they
don't so now we've got this thing that
is unresolved
that is uncertain
and that is unsettling as it relates to
the nfl's ability to get the remaining
208 regular season games played yeah no
it is concerning there's no question
about that it is i mean i'm not going to
sit here and say i'm in panic mode or
anything like that quite yet it is just
three players um well i mean when do
they think we're going to hear more
results from the rest of the tennessee
titans football today yeah as i said as
i said today sorry i don't know where i
mean because you've got the you you've
got the point of care testing i can give
you a quick idea as to whether or not
someone's positive and then you've got
the send it away and wait for the
results 24-hour turnaround my guess is
yesterday they tested every single
person in both of those organizations
and we'll see who's positive and who's
not in the contact tracing to see who
the three positive players and the five
non-players who are positive came into
any type of close contact with who may
need closer monitoring because they may
not be positive
yesterday right or today but they could
be positive tomorrow if they were in
contact with those folks so that's the
the you know the statement from roger
goodell made it clear that you know this
isn't a surprise they're not surprised
by this they were bracing for this of
course and i i think part of the problem
is it went so well see that was the
concern that's what a coach told me back
in august when the nfl started
subtly thumping its chest about how well
everything was going don't do it you're
going to make people complacent and
they're going to do stupid things more
on that coming up in a minute so chris
we expected this
we had hoped it wouldn't happen but it's
not a surprise and now the question is
how do they deal with it yeah i mean
that that's that's the big question to
me i mean first off just i mean i'm i'm
amazed like just at you know topical
level
that it's only three guys right i think
that amazes me sometimes that there was
an outbreak on the team and it's only
three guys at this point so it just it's
that's shocking to me and then like you
know is there any way or correlation or
connection between these guys right
that's the next thing you look at and i
think that's the other thing that jumps
out to you is you just go wait it's a d
lyman a long snapper and a tight end
they're not in the same room were they
on the were they sitting next to each
other on the plane ride home was there
something like that that's where i'm
just interested to see i mean just
because we're so new to the the the
virus still and i just it's amazing how
some people get it some people don't and
whatever else it is but that's amazing
to me mike and then lastly just on the
field i mean you talked about it like
maybe having a week of no practice no
preparation no walk-throughs just having
to do zoom meetings and you got to play
the pittsburgh steelers that couldn't
you couldn't be playing a worse uh worst
team to not have a week of no practice
and walk-throughs pittsburgh is the type
of team when you play them you usually
have to do extra walk-throughs because
their defense does so much crap and has
so many different things they do on that
side of the ball that it takes a
coaching staff a little bit more of time
than a normal week to kind of get ready
to play them so that was just the first
thing that i thought about football wise
mike
let me pose the question to you then
christopher that shireen williams posed
to me on yesterday afternoon's pft p.m 5
p.m eastern weekdays on peacock right
should the steelers
as a matter of basic competitive equity
be prevented from going to the facility
oh we can practice this week no
absolutely not
they're good they we've discussed this
already remember back you know we we had
these conversations
you know and especially again
i know maybe like you just get bad luck
and maybe somebody on the tennessee they
just got unlucky okay and that's cool
but
if we find out that one of these guys
did something stupid like we're going to
talk about some other teams here in a
second if we find out that then i don't
they don't deserve a free pass or
anything for one team's doing it the
right way i don't know what happened
with the other team but sorry no
pittsburgh gets to practice they're
ready to go their facility's clean their
players are good to go
see i initially was intrigued by
shereen's question but then i remembered
the point that you had hammered when we
talked about whether or not games would
go forward if a team is wiped out at a
given position group or can't dress 46
players too bad you should have kept the
virus out of your building it's the
ultimate pass fail test chris i'm not
even willing to cosign with the idea
that if somebody from the titans did
something stupid
it's pass fail yeah i guess these
mechanisms have been put in place to
ensure that the virus stays out of the
facility if you have failed to keep it
out of the facility that's on you if you
end up not being able to practice for an
entire week before a game against the
pittsburgh steelers or any team that's
on you that's not on the steelers the
steelers have kept it out of their
building you haven't kept it out of your
building and you're going to have to
find a way to get ready to play without
the benefit of practice or one of the
other possibilities that was reported
yesterday moving the game to monday
night then i guess the titans could get
some work in in advance of that game on
sunday although it's a fairly
significant game probably not a major
footprint game a one o'clock eastern
game easy to peel it out of the bunch be
very different if titans steelers was
the sunday night football game or the
monday night football game or the
thursday night football game think of
that wow if this was the week that the
titans were playing on thursday night
instead of the broncos and the jets who
once upon a time were known as the
titans we wouldn't have a thursday night
game
it just wouldn't happen no so there's an
element of luck of the draw here but
this is the warning shot this is the
thing and in
the best outcome here
chris yeah is
they can play the game as scheduled or
play it monday night or there's a way to
shuffle the schedule around
and we laid this out yesterday i started
cross-referencing various schedules you
could move this game to week seven when
the titans are due to have a buy week
seven the steelers are due to play the
ravens but both teams pittsburgh and
baltimore have a buy the next week very
easy move raven steelers to week eight
tighten steelers to week seven problem
solved the only problem is the steelers
aren't going to get a bye week because
they're going to practice all week then
not play a game and then the week that
was supposed to be there by what are
they going to be doing they're going to
be practicing right and getting ready to
play the ravens yeah instead of having
their week off because they played the
titans the day they were supposed to
play the ravens but hey but you know
what yeah this is
what is going to happen and that's why
when roger goodell says it's not a
competitive disadvantage to not have
fans present i think maybe the message
is you ain't seen nothing yet because
this season is going to be rife with
potential competitive disadvantages
because the overriding objective is what
chris get the games in yeah get the
games in i'm listen mike i'm not even in
favor of the monday night movement thing
either i mean i i don't think that's
fair to do to a pittsburgh team again
that's done everything right
and okay they have no issues on their
football team and oh you know you got to
end to follow that they got an in-state
battle the next week against
philadelphia so hey short week here
we're going to throw it on you all the
sudden i know you guys have done
everything right but the other team
screwed it up so sorry we're going to
penalize you too yeah i don't like that
i mean it is fortunate to what you said
that you can finagle
the the schedule there with those week
seven and week nine buys very
interesting that it worked out that way
i don't think it would always work out
that easily if this did continue to
happen but even that yes if you're
pittsburgh you're gonna sit there and go
wait wait so why are we the ones getting
screwed over here again like tell us why
we've done everything right so uh i
don't know where this goes the good
thing is it's only three players on the
tennessee titans so hopefully the
spread's not that big and regardless of
where these three players are at in the
coven 19 protocol and all those things
the titans will be able to survive
without these three guys where like i
know they might not be able to practice
but if they play football on sunday it
won't be like oh man they're loot they
miss bo brinkley and tommy hudson the
game is over no nope it's a competitive
disadvantage so from that aspect i mean
it's going to be a tough week for them
but it's not like their rosters flipped
over
well and here's the thing too
one of the reasons why there is
flexibility is because teams haven't had
bye weeks yet
once we get past
that point where teams have had their
weeks off right then there isn't going
to be that easy little shifted here
shifted there oh fine problem solved
right what we're going to have to do and
this is something peter king first
explained in the offseason the
possibility of having a week 18
and a week 19
which would entail the playing of games
that were postponed and that's in theory
another possibility here instead of
taking away the steelers bye week by
having them get ready this week
ultimately not playing but then play the
titans week seven play the ravens week
eight have no buy
just don't play the game this weekend
which still keeps them from having a buy
but they still have their buy later but
then week 18 they would play another
game and the post season would be bumped
back exactly by a week so every wild
card team would get a week off unless
you're one of the teams that has to play
week 18
and the
one seed in each conference would get
two weeks off yeah before they have to
play again but again this is all about
getting the games in that's bottom line
it's very machiavellian and i don't mean
that in a pejorative way
the ends justify the means and the means
maybe it is
in a pejorative way it's just the
reality of that word they got off what's
that mean pejorative that's way above my
pay scale what's that one sorry
it's something i use regularly um so
uh so so anyway uh
there's another item of good news let's
find the silver lining here no positives
for the vikings yeah yet amazing which
which tends to chris
support the idea and i've been hearing
this from people in the know for months
when you're outdoors or in a dome
stadium with great ventilation and
you're not in a confined space
the droplets yeah that presumably
depending upon what day you pull up the
cdc website or the primary source of i'm
serious the primary source of
transmission the droplets dissipate yeah
in that setting so if no vikings have
picked it up
that's
kind of uh you know practical
validation of that belief which
which is good because if one team does
have an outbreak
and it spreads to another team
that that makes it even harder to
continue with the season and it makes
the situation far worse so no positives
for the vikings they're shut down for 48
hours which actually is a competitive
disadvantage to them yeah they're trying
to win a game they got to play the
texans shut down 48 hours as of
yesterday that means no wednesday
practice their their schedule is screwed
up now that's a game that you could
argue could be moved or should be moved
to monday night because all the vikings
did was show up and play the team that
had the outbreak they've got no fault in
this at all no you're right that's that
that's that's the tough situation the
team like them who's done it right
you're right and now
yeah we forced you to close down because
the other team had issues and everything
there and and you know tuesday okay not
in the facility you could deal with that
as you know uh or anybody that follows
the nfl tuesday is the player's day off
it's the coach's day to get the game
plan ready deep dive they grind it out
all day long so they don't need to be at
the office or that they can live with
that day right you can do a lot of that
at home yeah you're going to miss some
meetings and whatever else but we know
that coaches are making that happen
but wednesday practice
that's a tough one to miss certainly and
that's probably going to be tough to
swallow for a guy like mike zimmer
because it is such an important practice
they are 0 and
they're playing another 0-3 football
team and it's where the meat and
potatoes of your game plan go in on that
day and you really get you know a feel
for the other team and how you're going
to attack that team that day on a first
and second down basis basically is what
you go through so uh that will be tough
and uh stinks for the vikings yeah but
what do you do i don't know what you do
there hopefully they can get their test
back and they can get back there
practicing tomorrow to where they only
miss one day and they can do their best
to manage it from there
also the officiating crew from sunday's
titans vikings game cleat blakeman's
crew off this week in an abundance of
caution remember the officials aren't
subject to the same frequency of testing
the same type of standards that apply to
players and non-playing personnel with
teams they basically just show up at the
game site day or two before probably day
before get tested there may get tested
in their home market during the week but
not nearly the kind of everyday everyday
every day every day testing
and
it's good that they test every day
someone told me before the season that
the league is likely to consider
testing every day and continue that all
season long and after this outbreak in
tennessee i think it makes it even more
sensible right but i think at a certain
level it does desensitize
people
to the seriousness of the situation
because on one hand the routine of being
tested every day holds you accountable
on the other hand you can kind of shrug
at things like i get tested every day i
yeah i get to you know but yeah you may
be positive just because you get tested
every day doesn't mean you've got to go
and i i hear people say that and some of
you may hear this as well
like
if people are engaged in behavior that
is just kind of dancing around the
borderline of what is and what isn't
acceptable for the purposes of limiting
the spread and they say oh i got tested
last week it's like
so what's that who cares i know did you
get tested right now do we know right
now whether or not you're positive so i
think some of that attitude is going to
creep in because remember the vast
majority of these individuals are
between 21 and 25 or 26 and number one
their brains may not have fully
developed yet number two they are young
they want to do things they want to live
their lives they have a certain amount
of fatigue and they may allow themselves
to think i get tested every day i can go
do things
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports